let's go on to derivatives that limit of
the slope of the secant line that we
just talked about is called the first
derivative ok so we're Desiree had
suggested a graph of the slope of FX f
of X that looks like this that is just
the graph of the derivative right so
instead of slope of f of X I could have
called this the derivative or more
precisely the first derivative of the
function of X also often referred to as
f prime of X ok ok so the derivative F
prime of X of a function f of X is just
the slope the process of differentiation
what's that that is the process of
finding the limit of the slope of the
secant line or the process of finding
the derivative or the process of
describing the slope of a nonlinear
function ok of course as you've already
realized the derivative or the slope of
the nonlinear function is itself a
function of X it may be also a nonlinear
function of X such as this or it may be
a linear function of X as Desiree
initially suggested
okay okay okay so if you take a function
f of X and you differentiate it you'll
get a different looking function called
F prime of X and that in it that's a new
function if you put the value of x into
this new function then this new function
will give you the slope of the original
function not the original function
itself okay okay take a function f of X
if you differentiate it or find its
derivative you will get a new function
which we call F prime of X and if you
take the value a particular value of x
that you had put into this function and
you put it into the derivative then this
new function will give you this slope of
the original function at that point at
the chosen point X rather than the value
of the original function okay that's
true by definition but it's just
something to keep in mind okay and it'll
become a little clearer once we see some
examples okay just some notation there
are lots of different ways of denoting
the derivative and so and they're all
interchangeable and you should just get
used to seeing them in their myriad
forms okay and if you are you know
remember we're learning math driving
around in the back of the pickup truck
so when you do that it gets a little
annoying to have lots of different names
for the same thing
but it's it's a good way to apprehend
reality and you know so just just become
fluent in the different names okay so
this is f prime of X or F prime or Y
Prime you'll see a common one is dy of
DX or dfx over DX yes I'll probably use
them interchangeably you'll see that the
literature will use it interchangeably
so that's my excuse there are there sort
of cultural antecedents to these things
so you know f prime is the one that you
that you must see with economists dy/dx
is more what you see with pure
mathematicians and these other ones you
don't see that often but you see a
little bit okay okay so that derivative
i just gave you all the different
notation its interpretation is always as
the slope okay it's the slope of the
function f of X now in particular
applications you might interpret it as
something slightly different it's still
the slope you might think of it as the
rate of change of F of x for some unit
change in X that really is the slope or
in economic and financial applications
you might think of it as the marginal
value of x you'll see this term marginal
value of x so if you've had no economics
or finance before this is a new term and
it always means the derivative of F
of X okay and therefore it always means
the rate of change of F of X for a unit
change in X okay okay so here's an
example that you'll see in economics
quite a lot cost functions suppose that
instead of f of X i have a function c of
q q is now the independent variable it
takes the place of X and C is is the
function and it has this formulaic form
and it might look something like this q
might be the quantity produced and this
is the total cost as a function of
quantity produced actually it probably
won't look like this in other words I
didn't check to see what Q cubed minus
10 q squared plus 4 TQ looks like and in
fact I can be sure that it doesn't look
like that
it should go up it should go up as cue
goes up but you see that's that's the
power of calculus because because you
you can you know once once you have
facility with calculus and you see a
function you don't have to graph it to
see what how it behaves under different
circumstances okay okay the marginal
cost seek prime Q is is going to be the
the slope of this function so just
suppose that the function does look like
this what's interesting about this
function is its derivative is going to
look interesting right and I'll show you
so let's just draw what that derivative
would look like
okay Desiree do you want to help me or
did somebody else want to help me
somewhere here what would be the slope
so okay so here is the slope first of
all is the slope positive or negative
positive is it a big positive number or
smoke it's a big positive number right
so we're probably somewhere up here
whoops hope I don't destroy this okay
you're frowning so here this okay so
think of the tangent line at this point
right yeah the tangent line goes up like
that right and that has that's a steeply
upward sloping line so that has a very
large positive slope okay and so that's
why I've got a plot somewhere here for
low values of Q this slope is very going
to be very high okay at this point okay
this is why I got a point ER so i don't
have to stretch like that at this at
this point what's the slope of the
function zero right so 0 is down here so
i know that it probably looks like this
but i don't know what's going to happen
after this point whether it'll go up go
down right so after the point 0 what's
the slope here negative right so that
means it's going straight through like
that okay here what's the slope zero
again so somewhere there I've got to be
coming back
okay and then here the slope is positive
so it's going to be up here and then
here it's zero again this is going to be
like that and then the slope is negative
okay i know that was a little quick if
you have not met this kind of analysis
before I'm going to do it one more time
so you get a sense of it this is this
relationship between the function and
it's derivative is very central okay and
I don't care if you don't learn how to
differentiate but I do want you to
understand at least graphically the
relationship between a function and it's
derivative okay because that'll get you
a long way that getting that intuition
behind it is really important it's not
important to understand the formulas ok
ok so let's let's do it for a simpler
kids
let's go back to X and f of X and
suppose that I have the following
function okay sorry what's your name
with the pink should Kathy right okay so
I'm going to ask you because you were
frowning when this happened so this is
my function and I'll describe this in in
English let's say this is a function
that starts out steep and upward sloping
for values of x close to zero steep and
upward sloping and it's its stead stays
very steep but it gets less and less
steep as x increases until let's say it
gets to the value of five at the VAT
where x is equal to five it's not steep
at all it's not upward sloping at all
it's flat and after that its downward
sloping so for values of x between 0 and
5 its upward sloping for values of x
above 5 its downward sloping okay okay
so let's put that up and I want your
Kathy to tell me what this slope would
look like sorry that has to get up there
a little bit higher
ok
okay so Kathy for values of x less than
five we know that the function is upward
sloping will this if I had to plot the
slope here for values of x less than
five will the number be a positive
number or a negative number or 0
positive right and if it's close to zero
is it going to be a big positive number
or a small positive number in other
words you so by positive you mean that
its upward sloping is it very upward
sloping here or is it only a little bit
upward sloping is it gradually upward
sloping it'll be a big positive number
right so it's going to be up here now at
the value x equals 5 what's the slope
going to be zero so that's probably a
point on this function the F prime of X
4 values greater than 5 we said that the
function is downward sloping and it gets
more steep as x increases so downward
sloping means it has a negative slope so
it's probably something like that and
looking at this it's probably a straight
line so the function that describes the
slope of the function above ie its
derivative here is a straight line okay
if you plot if you if you plug the value
5 into f of X you'll get some number
whatever that number happens to be
if you plug the value 5 into its
derivative you'll get the slope of the
original function everybody see that
this is what I need you to internalize
okay it doesn't have to be in the next
two minutes but in the course of the
next year or so yes oh yeah by
definition when it's going down it has a
negative slope that's right so at that
point it has a slope of zero because
you're flat so generally if you know if
you're if you start up in the positive
territory if you start out with positive
slope and then you hit a point where
you're flat for most functions that
you'll see beyond that you'll have a
negative slope for it not to have a
negative slope there it you know it
would have to be an unusual function for
example if this was a plateau then this
slope would go like that and then would
hang out at the x axis for a while okay
yes yeah yes so that goes back to this
bullet point the derivative depends upon
X in some way that is the derivative is
also a function of X okay when X is
substituted into the derivative the
result is the slope of the original
function okay so what I'm saying here is
this is the original function f of X if
i plug in 5 into that function i get
some value I didn't tell you what that
is but
let's say that's 20 I then work out it
the derivative of this function either
by differentiating or by some graphical
method of determining slopes and I find
that the derivative of that function
which I call F prime of X looks like
that if i plug 5 into F prime of X then
I get a number here 00 is the slope of
the original function ok yes no no this
was a simple case where actually I
started out with a quadratic function
until they happen to have derivatives
that are straight lines and you'll see
why in a second but look here here I had
a more complicated function and it's
derivative looked less complicated than
the function itself but nevertheless
fairly complicated in general it's
usually the case that the derivative
will look a little simpler closer to
linearity than the function itself
remember the derivative the
interpretation of the derivative is the
rate of change or how the function
changes for a unit change in the input
variable so very commonly the
instantaneous speed if you're driving
from here to DC your every instant you
have a different speed you know you you
there aren't any cars in front of you
you're driving at 70 miles an hour and
or maybe more and then you hear a police
car you're going to drive at 40 okay so
that is so a different instance you have
different speed think of that in the
same vein as a nonlinear function at
different points different values of X
you have different slopes
okay when you're going very fast you're
getting towards DC very quickly when
your slope is very steep you're you're
covering a lot of distance in this axis
very quickly okay so in general in in
any kind mean that's just a speed
example but but in any kind of social
analysis or scientific analysis you'll
have phenomena that are related to other
phenomena that's the functional
relationship we talked about in the last
session and then you'll want to know
whether that functional relationship is
you know is it what's the rate of change
of that functional relationship is if
you change X a little bit will you have
a huge change in Y or only a little
change in Y okay so you know as an
example here if I if I if this is a cost
function if I if I'm at this point and I
increase my output because the slope
here is very gradual my total cost won't
rise too much but if I'm here and I
increase my output a little bit my total
cost will rise a lot and there's
probably an underlying technological
reason for the shape of this cost
function for example it could be that
here you are surpassing the limits of
capacity you know if you think about a
classroom if I add an extra student into
this class there's going to be no change
in the quality of everybody's experience
but if we're off if this were full and i
added an extra student then i might have
to expand to another classroom and so
Mike my cost let's say would increase
substantially okay yes
no you could do that for every function
in fact you so if you didn't know
calculus at all and you simply SAT there
working out tangents and then plotting
the slope that you derive from that
tangent and associating it with each
value of x you would be able to
construct the derivative function ok
calculus is simply a method of
constructing the formula for that
function without having to do the
graphical analysis ok ok so that's the
interpretation of the derivative
everybody ok so far ok now of course and
this is a common trick that people do in
math once you understand something and
you think you've grasped it then they
ask you to iterate the logic that is do
you know repeat the logic on itself